[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hey,
there, I/O Live.
Todd Kerpelman
here, and I am here
in the Experiments with Google
Dome with Teo Soares, who
is the team lead on
Experiments with Google.
Welcome.
TEO SOARES: Thank you.
Happy to be here.
TODD KERPELMAN: So what is
Experiments with Google?
TEO SOARES:
Experiments with Google
is a platform where we showcase
projects that developers have
made using Google technologies.
We have close to 1,500 of them.
A lot of them are open source.
Anybody can download
them and play around.
Anybody can submit their own.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, and
so here at the booth today,
at the Dome, you've got some
of your favorite experiments
that are showing off.
TEO SOARES: Yeah,
we have 10 of them.
Do you want to try this one out?
TODD KERPELMAN: I would.
What is this one behind me here?
TEO SOARES: So this one
is called Move Mirror,
and it's a demo of a pose
estimation model from Google
that lets you use just
any regular webcam--
we're using a phone here--
to find the pose
data in an image.
And then in this demo,
what we are doing
is finding an image
that matches what
you are doing in
front of the camera
from one of 90,000 images
we have in the database.
TODD KERPELMAN: Awesome.
Well, let's give it a try.
My kids told me about flossing,
which apparently is a thing,
but I'm not going to do
it because I don't want
to embarrass my kids that much.
I'm just going to bounce
side to side instead.
All right, then
I'm going to wave.
All right, thank you.
And now we're going to
move on to the next one.
Let's go.
TEO SOARES: So this
is a game built
with a Google library
called TensorFlow.JS
that lets you train an
AI right in the browser.
And what we've done with it
here is play a dancing game
where you're going to train
your little dancer using
hand gestures and see how
many points you can score.
TODD KERPELMAN: And so through
the power of machine learning,
this is going to
recognize my hand
gestures all within the
browser using TensorFlow.JS?
No talking to the
cloud or anything?
TEO SOARES: Exactly.
Nothing is ever
going to a server.
It's all happening
right in the browser.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
All right, well, I've
got to give that a try
and make my little
Jelly Bean guy dance.
Let's do it.
I'm ready.
You ready?
Come on, Jelly Bean.
Dance to the left.
To the right.
Three out.
Left.
Come on, keep dancing,
little Jelly Bean.
You can do it.
Oh, no!
Oh, I got one wrong.
All right, look at that.
I get a medal for dancing--
the one and only time I will
get a medal for dancing.
Let's move on to the next one.
So what's going on here?
TEO SOARES: This is
an augmented reality
experiment that lets you draw
really simple things in AR.
We called it [INAUDIBLE].
What we've done for this demo
is to use Cloud Anchors, which
is the new technology that
we announced at this I/O
to let two phones
join the same room
and draw together
on the same drawing.
And that can happen
across platforms,
so we have one Android
and one iPhone.
TODD KERPELMAN: Awesome,
so let's give this a try.
Maybe I will hold
up a phone, and you
can draw a little something
on your other device.
So let's see what
you're drawing here.
Oh, drawing over here.
Oh, it's a smiley face.
Woo, and we are chatting
in augmented reality.
It's the future.
Thank you so much for the tour.
So if I'm a
developer, and I want
to either get inspired
to make something amazing
or want to show off something
amazing that I have made,
where do I go?
TEO SOARES: You go
to g.co/experiments.
That's where you find
our 1,500 experiments.
A lot of them are open source,
or you can submit your own.
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, sounds good--
g.com/experiments.
And hey, if you like this video,
maybe want to see a few more
like it, head on over to
g.co/io/guide and see more
videos just like this one.
Thanks for watching.
We'll see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]